bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france pourquoi
l'administration by john revient pas sur
cet axe imposé dernièrement par donald
trump
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de continuité
entre les républicains et les démocrates
sur ces sujets moi j'ai jamais pensé que
l'arrivée de monsieur by des néo
démocrates allaient changer les
relations avec l'union européenne ou les
relations des cas chine
donc nous sommes encore dans un contexte
conflictuel alors l'organisation
mondiale du commerce est censé améliorer
les choses mais vous fais remarquer que
celle omc qui autorisait chacune des
parties a finalement un toit hier des
taxes donc à réagir par rapport aux des
sciatiques de l'autre partie dans que
moi l'om ses joueurs depuis quelques
années âge un jeu assez dangereux je
répète vous l'avais dit dans la
présentation tout ça dure depuis 16 17
ans à propos de boeing airbus on se
pacse mutuellement nos importations
quant à que les exportations l'autre des
boeing et des airbus
et je répète à mon avis il américains
vont pas nous faire de cadeau sur ces
questions là à puisqu'il comprend la
chine pour cesser le conflit commercial
le plus long le plus difficile à traiter
aussi pourquoi est ce que c'est si
difficile parce que derrière lui que
derrière tout ça vous avez des l'enjeu
économique et géopolitique
airbus et boeing sont quand même les
deux les deux leaders en matière de
fabrication d'avions
il ya des enjeux de souveraineté et et
chacune des parties depuis celle 17 ans
puisque ça a commencé en 2004 accuse
l'autre partie de subventionner sa
production à travers des aides de ce
qu'on appelle des aides d'état
bon et puis voilà donc on s'installe là
dedans est temps qu'on se met pas autour
de la table en essayant de
progressivement progressivement j'allais
dire réduire et de façon réciproque
les taxes imposées sur l'autre partie
on n'y arrivera pas il y avait cette
escalade qui a commencé bien avant
un qui a commencé en 2004 l'om c'est à
carder faire de manière un peu passive
mais l'om c est aujourd'hui un organisme
international faible mon avis a fait
bloquer donc on est dans la bi latéral
et on va voir si le président macro et
il prédit en by dane arrive à se parler
si l'heureux représentant pour le
commerce
pour nous c'est l'union européenne un
qui va négocier sur tout mais je pense
que monsieur mac ont un rôle à jouer
vis-à-vis de bruxelles et vis-à-vis du
négociateur européen donc moi je
souhaite une désescalade des taxes pour
les relations entre les états unis et
l'union européenne
mais ça me paraît pas gagné alors du
côté de joe biden c'est vrai on le sent
vouloir véritablement assainir les
relations maintenant avec l'union
européenne
vous parlez vous évoquez emmanuel macron
qui lui aussi va aller dans ce sens à
quoi ça tombe finalement est ce qu'on
peut espérer au final à un dénouement du
conflit des mois je n'attends pas
grand-chose dans les mois qui viennent
il y avoir un écart entre les mots et
les choses entre les intentions et la
réalité est ce que l'union européenne va
parler d'une seule voix nous sommes pas
brixi donc nous sommes 27 pays européens
être concernés par les négociations est
ce qu'on va être 27 pays est d'accord
sur la manière d'aborder nos nouvelles
races et être les nouvelles relations
avec la nouvelle administration
américaine
du côté américain c'est plus simple
puisqu'ils sont tout seul si je puis
dire c'est un pays et ils ont pas ils en
passe coordonnées à priori mais moi je
pense qu'on veuille dans ce contexte
compliqué et je souhaite qu'on vienne
vraiment des relations multilatérales
vous avez vu que la nouvelle
administration américaine va revenir
probablement à la colorisation mondiale
de la santé qui reviennent autour de la
table pour les problèmes d'écologie il
revient il revient dans l'accord de
paris
idole de la courbe 21 vis-à-vis du mc du
commerce et des taux de change moi je
vois rien de changé du fait de la
continuité
surtout qu'à un autre conflit celui de
la taxe sur les géants du numérique qui
vient un peu se superposer à celui ci le
conflit entre boeing et airbus
il ya la menace aussi de nouveaux droits
de douane sur des produits français
encore comme les fromages les produits
de beauté ou les sacs à main là encore
est ce que cela risque un peu plus dans
vos lits mais finalement ce le bras de
fer que l'on connaît déjà et les
relations entre les etats-unis et la
france particulièrement l'europe ce
chercheur en matière de taxation des
gaffes à puisqu'il n'y a pas d'accord
vraiment au niveau européen j'ai raison
pour laquelle la france a menacé
d'introduire sa propre taxe sur les
gaffes à mais tout ça ça crée un climat
de défiance mois plutôt que d'imposer
les gaffes américaine ge préféré que 1
du côté européen par une politique
industrielle audacieuse au niveau de
l'europe
on essaye de données vers des la la
création de gaffard européenne je pense
que c'est ça la bonne réplique aux
gaffes américaine fut pas sûr que la
bonne réplique ça soit une taxation
d'autant plus que les pays européens et
27 sont pas aujourd'hui d'accord entre
eux sur ces problèmes de taxation des
gaffes 1 donc tout ça ça crée un climat
de défiance et je répète il faut
vraiment et ça c'est un problème
politique c'est une option politique de
part et d'autre amorcé une désescalade
mais quand vous regardez l'histoire
américaine les administrations
démocrates n'ont pas été plus gentille
avec l'europe que les administrations
républicaines ne pas plus gentil avec
l'europe ou avec la chine donc là c'est
un domaine où il ya de la continuité à
mon avis entre républicains et
démocrates
merci beaucoup à vous question de
boissieu d'avoir été en direct avec nous
je rappelle que vous êtes vice président
du cercle des économistes en